first thanks to Robert Davis and they'd
kemon ik for providing a chance for me
to reprieve a piece of writing that it
did 25 years ago I'm not an
archaeologist I would never have gone
back to it I think but for the occasion
that this meeting represents it's a book
that grew out of an interest I had then
and continue to have in the care and
feeding of scholarly communities mostly
in their institutional circumstances
which means mostly at universities
although I've also done some work on
foundations the genesis for the book
which had the rather clunky title
International Studies and academic
enterprise a chapter in the enclosure of
American learning all academic titles
have to have a colon and then something
even longer after it and I conformed I
do it their way the book itself is in
part the story I wish to take up with
you today at the launching of this neh
Summer Scholars Institute in 1975 I was
here as an assistant professor at
Barnard and Columbia and was hired as a
part-time consultant to the
International training and research
program at the Ford Foundation I had
very specific responsibilities I was
supposed to go on the road and on the
road meant visiting a half-dozen
campuses receiving Ford Foundation money
for their various area studies programs
mine were specifically the University of
Washington Michigan State
Syracuse Duke 10 and the University of
North Carolina I don't think it
irreverent to suggest that I was not
part of the group that visited Harvard
Chicago Berkeley in Columbia they were
the first tier institutions I was a
second tier person in this but I have
the same set of responsibilities just a
lower profile
it was my job to find out or whether
these schools could get along that is
their International Studies programs
could get along if not prosper atleast
survive without any further pump priming
from the Ford Foundation
pretty straightforward situation I
didn't quite know what I was getting
into it's a little bit like showing up
at a family and asking whether they can
do without the breadwinner but sure
enough again being in cooperative sort I
got into the spirit okay it took me a
little while to figure out what the
background of this situation was but I
soon found out that the Ford Foundation
had spent by this time again mid
seventies at least a decade trying to
move its money to another table which
was the phrase use in-house although
nothing so indelicate as that was said
to the Michigan State Syracuse
duke-north Carolina folks move the money
to another table the president of the
Ford Foundation McGeorge Bundy after
tumultuous career first at Harvard which
wasn't so tumultuous but in Lyndon
Johnson's Washington DC it was certainly
tumultuous when he came to the Ford
Foundation in 1965 1966 committed to
getting the Ford Foundation deeply
involved in the problems of urban
America which did not mean putting all
its money into Slovak Studies or East
Asian Studies he asked at a conference
at the Ford Foundation with all the
director mucky-mucks who were at the
various institutions I put the question
this way in the negative interrogative
form that I think was popular in a
khadeem at that point is it not possible
that in some geographic areas countries
and disciplines sufficient areas
specialists have been trained to man the
necessary positions provide the basic
research and reproduce themselves in
adequate numbers without special pomp
that's the Ford Foundation's exit to
this how ten years after making that
statement they still hadn't been able to
get up I took that as a very serious
commentary on the health of the
university that they couldn't say no to
universities but the Ford Foundation was
determined to do so and I was sent out
to provide them with an explanation for
why they were doing it and then I could
be pointed at it I guess if it didn't
pan out that way so the question is
formulated was this as International
Studies area studies was the term that
was being used area programs all sorts
of different phrases but we all I think
know what we're talking about in this
area had International Studies become a
permanent presence in the offerings of
the major universities where fraud money
had gone to build up their programs no
question in the Ford Foundation's mind
and I think in reality that without Ford
money in the 1950s the growth of area
studies program simply would not have
occurred it was not until the mid 60s
that federal money began to flow and the
question of whether it would have flown
floated in the direction that it did I
think is very much to the credit if you
will of the Ford Foundation for starting
the spicket going did International
Studies faculty have the clout to
protect the turf without initially
without the initially enabling
underwriting by Ford would federal
dollars do the job that was the next
hope for eternal optimist or would
universities even university endowments
be used to fund these chairs these
programs that had been previously funded
by Henry Ford's profits I offered a
two-part answer again consistent with my
company man approach well the first part
was can they survive yes of course I was
not in International Studies myself so
it kind of a disinterested
for me to take yes they would be able to
satisfy McGeorge Bundy read my memo and
really thought this ought to go
immediately into a book which would then
add to the residents of this position so
one day in 1967 was prepared to say
International Studies are here to stay
Makka he took another eighteen years
before this book was really ready no no
that twenty years eighteen years before
he published it in book form yes
International Studies is here to stay so
Edie and Robert asked me to come back
and talk to you so I had to go back and
read my book because I had I had placed
a bet on certain developments now if I
were really doing this right and haven't
because I was suggested earlier neh is a
little tight with its money so what I
didn't think was called for was to do
another book on this project so I went
back selectively let us say but I offer
you today three data points that
surprise suggests I was right which
means that McGeorge Bundy was even
writer earlier but you and I must say my
lunch companions today can offer
contrary evidence or two this with
there's a public apology for what has
happened but the first data point that I
offer you is a local one our Columbia in
the year 2011 there about 3,600 faculty
here in the Arts and Sciences and I
would include in that the School of
International and public affairs and
Barnard College and exclude the sciences
leaves us with in humanities and social
science faculty of about 750 faculty
the the Columbia non-western language
and culture departments consists of 134
faculty 134 is the numerator 750 s the
denominator Columbia University's social
science departments the history
department is a huge department although
the numbers include Barnard faculty as
well but there 125 of us to be sure a
bunch are in Mardin Europe now and a
substantial number although I report
declining number in American history but
in East Asia Saudis 14 in Latin American
Studies 9 in Middle Eastern Studies 7 in
African Studies five are in Russians
studies for or and in South Asian
Studies 3 the relative placement of
Russian I'll come back to in a moment in
political science that about 70 faculty
25 of them seem to be mostly in
comparative and international relations
relating to parts of the world outside
of Western Europe economics about the
same portion in international
development 25 of 70 in anthropology
more than half of the 50 or so
anthropologists have regional focuses
outside the Atlantic world let us call
it religion even more so 24 members 10
of them dealing with Western religion or
Christianity more specifically but 8
with Asian religions and regions and 5
Middle Eastern Region Judaism Islam as
well in some about one-third of the
Columbia humanities and social science
faculty have a strong if not dominant
non-western regional interest this is
supported by the numbers of folks in the
area Institute's some 400 members
African Studies 93 memories Latin
American Institute 109 Middle East
Institute 83 the Herman Institute 61 the
South Asian Institute 40 Columbia has
six of the hundred and twenty-five
national resource centers for advanced
language instruction no I think that
helps my my case what I do then can be
generous and suggest that it's not all
that way there have been some changes
since 1967 and there been changes since
1985 the biggest difference I think the
biggest differences have been
geo-political and they have an impact on
certain regions more than others
the USSR is no longer the Cold War is
over we live in what can be defined I
think primarily as a post 9/11 world in
which non-state or weak state States
Harbor or sponsor terror as a grave
concern the outer rim of what had been
the Soviet Union now a dozen independent
nations who twenty years ago
or were all we thought maybe not all of
you being more perceptive but most of us
thought or could be spoken for in anyway
were spoken from Moscow this is to
acknowledge the shifting focus of
attention by US policymakers and I think
Bahrain an informed public and that
shift is toward the Middle East where
the United States is fort and it's
fighting three wars in the last 20 years
I guess but I have not documented that
there are fewer American correspondents
today in Moscow than in Cairo and that
my Barnard students anyway are more
likely to be studying Arabic and Chinese
more than Russian and Islamic
fundamentalism
when larsa's economics so there's been a
shift no question about it but it's
within the International Studies
community and those shifts had taken
place in the early years as well because
they are responsive at some level to
what's going on
outside the university and good for that
the second data point that I would
suggest as to the permanence for the
extent that anything can be permanent of
International Studies as an academic
presence is its penetration of liberal
arts colleges that was not part of the
deal
that was no Ford Foundation wasn't
interested in undergraduate programs a
liberal arts colleges our title six is
really only modestly and belatedly
taking an interest in in liberal arts
colleges but look again again I use now
the Barnard College example the history
department at Barnard has 14 people to
Latin Americanist in africanist and East
Asians and South Asia
long with more than European and
American specialists
Barnard has three people by my count or
who have an active interest in Eurasia
bringing it down to the most specific
way and Cathy Nefario she and Alex cool
you'll both meet during the course of
the Institute I went last spring up to
Hobart College in Geneva New York to do
a site visit of the history department
the departments a little smaller than
boards ten people but it had an East
Asian is a Latin Americans and African
as' and a Russian list now again to be
sure that things move the Russian is is
likely to be replaced upon her
retirement by either a South Asian store
a what they were calling global
historian that's unfortunate for those
who wish to pursue Islamic studies or
Russian history
but in terms of the International
Studies community hiring a South Asian
history place a Russian Asst is not the
same as hiring an expert on Minnesota or
on the Cotswolds
we are still talking about in that part
of the world that we supposedly had
neglected through most of our history so
my argument was I think I can still get
out of the room with saying that this is
at least a steady state or a normal
situation exists that International
Studies reached a point and has
reasonably effectively applied toed
drawing sources from other parts of the
university and I think in more long-term
sources that is it's coming out of the
university itself it's not somebody with
making a mail drop and leaving two
million dollars for a chair and middle
east in history or whatever but then I
had a second answer and the first answer
was yes we're okay
the second answer was an onion begin to
sound a little bit like a lawyer but
there's something else offering a second
answer was even if no not so bad
my wife argues who's going to outlive me
she assures me I will have on my
gravestone the result of being
practicing Catholic where she is a
residual presbyterian that the epigraph
epitaph will say something like yeah
that wasn't so bad they will be able to
live with the circumstances whatever
they are so this is the fatalistic
Catholic rendering hour even if know
that his international studies would not
survive that academic international
studies was in a death spiral the
concentrating all of the nation's
expertise in foreign parts in our
universities as was done in the postwar
decades that the Ford Foundation was
prominently in play was not necessarily
the best and certainly not the only way
to assure or enhance America's capacity
for understanding the
workings of parts of the world at some
remove from our own borders that is I
argued that the recent and Ford
Foundation primed academic enclosure of
International Studies was not an unmixed
blessing and that correspondingly it son
fencing would not be a total disaster so
if to take that position an argument
needed to be made to counter what I
called in my disinterested way the
self-serving efforts of well-placed
academics and Dean's who argued
otherwise that the sky would fall and
America would revert to its pre Ford
Foundation condition of abject ignorance
about the outer world and that every
minute happened to us would be our just
desserts
at that point not so said Ari my
argument required the assertion of the
existence of an American tradition of
close observation of the outer world
prior to the creation of the American
University and for some time after that
operating at some remove from the
University I was not unaware of the
arguments advanced about American
indifference to intellectual activities
they extend at least as far back as
Alexis de Tocqueville in the 1830s and
then around here on Morningside Heights
we always have richard hofstadter who
could talk eloquently about anti
intellectualism as a powerful if not
determining strain in American thought
and even today if we listen to
I think Newt Gingrich is the most recent
propagator of the notion of American
exceptionalism that's there we do
sometimes regard ourselves as a city
upon a hill where everyone should be
watching us I'm right here this is how I
do it that's there but it is not the
only approach that is offered so I'm
suggesting a revisionist interpretation
I'm engaged in a reclamation project
give earlier Americans who took up the
study of foreign parts they do
first among these and one could go back
even earlier but I think the first among
these are folks right on the very edge
of the end of the revolution who
established commercial relations with
parts of the world that colonial America
had not touched on East Asia is very
much part of it but so is the Pacific
Northwest where the contact with Russia
right as an American activity began this
is the 1790s contact with the Indian
Ocean American slavers extended
themselves into East Africa weren't
limited to West Africa when they were
going about their grisly business in the
1790s until the slave trade had been
closed down but it's the missions the
Christian missions that are the large
force I think for bringing attention to
Americans of the rest of the world in
1810 the American Board of Commissioners
of foreign missions is founded in Boston
Massachusetts its intention was to bring
the Christian guard to the heathen but
doing so requires a two-way exchange and
that was recognized I think from the
outset Americans needed to acquire
language skills and needed to have
extended exposure to distant parts that
is they had to be in country and for
extended periods of time
you didn't go to Burma on a two-week
trip you went for 30 years and you hope
someone came and got you after those 30
years but if you didn't you hope
somebody came back and got your kids who
you would send back to Williams or
Amherst or later to Mount Holyoke and
then they would come back and provide
another generation of this activity so
it was India Burma Smyrna Hawaii by 1860
twelve hundred and fifty American
missionaries are on station and when
they're on station there are reports
that come back or there are fundraising
efforts
there are memoirs again I can remember
as a kid and continues to today
much of the American Catholic community
learns about Africa when the returning
missionaries come back and make a pitch
for the second collection on a Sunday
morning and described their their
encounters well there was an
intellectual level I think some cuts
above that in the 19th century but it
was a basis for American understanding
of what was going on out there indeed
one of the risk in the missionary
community was some of the missionaries
going native that they would become so
identified with the folks that they were
supposed to be converting that they
would instead be converted the other way
this a prominent leader of the American
Board adren and John Judson
congregations he who has undertaken to
deliver a nation from the Thorold um of
sin has objects in view more important
than the researches of Antiquaries or
the companionship of savants the
president of brown worried about sending
off his graduates into the missionary
world and but had to be fully aware of
the temptation to which missionaries are
exposed when the treasures of a new
language and a peculiar form of
literature are presented before them he
therefore guarded himself against this
with peculiar stiffness so that the
attraction that a number of you have to
parts of the world were very much part
of that there although you were meant to
resist it under earlier institutional
circumstances and now you can let it all
hang out the long reach of the American
missionary community although admittedly
less so in the Slavic world continues on
into the 20th century how many Americans
learned about China from Pearl Book how
many Americans learned about Asia from
Henry Luce or take it up a couple of
notches how many Harvard students
learned about East Asia from John Kay
Fairbank all of them coming out of
missionary roots so what about the 19th
century non missionary interest in the
wider world
curiosity wonder lust are folks
Americans on the out on the lookout for
literary materials God's Judson said
before he went off to Burma for 30 years
when his father wanted him to become a
lawyer in Boston he said I shall never
live in Boston notion committed to some
other activity that was there even among
the non missionary community John Legend
grew up in the area of Stonington
Connecticut in the 1750s walked across
most of catherine the great's Russia in
1787 before he was turned back and then
died in Cairo awaiting a caravan to
truck across the soul so Saharan Africa
you did not have to be a British
academic to feel that kind of wonder
list or join John Lloyd Stephens who
have mr. Vieau Columbia College graduate
1841 writing travels in Central America
Chiapas and Yucatan Herman Melville
going to the South Sea Islands and
coming up with TP and normally then
there are independent scholars John
Pickering a lawyer from Boston but also
a linguist a linguist in that he was
proficient in I quote all the European
and Semitic languages plus Arabic
Turkish Syriac Egyptian hieroglyphics
melee in several dialects or there was
William hickling Prescott who became a
scholar of the Spanish Spanish conquest
in South America John Lothrop model II
the rise of the Dutch Republic in the
1850s or Francis Parkman somewhat later
on the French explorations settlement
and then disgorgement in Canada Emerson
and Thoreau interest in the Orient
albeit by translation but more serious
level on the diplomat Eugene Schuyler I
mentioned this morning translating
together in the 1860s or writing on the
Turkish Belgian war
in 1876 and travels as a diplomat
American diplomat through the newly
conquered Russian areas in Central Asia
notes on a journey in Russian Turkestan
again mentioned this morning or the
elder George Kennan writing on Siberia
and the exile system and then of course
his son later on writing about Russian
plans for the post-war era so
journalists of a very high order I think
not really to be seen as having a
parallel today where correspondents are
expected to jump around from hot spot to
hot spot and just did not continue to
support that kind of activity which
reached a different a non-academic
audience in those days John Gunther the
I was there journalism some of it based
on considerable exposure some of it are
kind of today it's Tuesday and I'm in
Arabia activity war correspondents
William Henry Chamberlain the Christian
Science monitor's man in Moscow between
the wars or Cyrus Saul's burger
the New York Times me then they were and
I used the term to describe them
although the term was used this morning
by Robert and I think it's an accurate
term I called him academic pioneers
I would call them academic ambassadors
oh that is that they took on a
responsibility of making connections
between the non-academic community the
rest of the world if you will and the
university american universities took on
recognizable shape that is if we went to
Johns Hopkins today Johns Hopkins looks
a little different but not very
different from its origins in the 1870s
with Hopkins that led the way to the
structure of the American University
that we know and then there were other
newcomers of that period
Cornell Stanford University Chicago some
of the state universities particularly
the University California and Michigan
but then there were also transformed
colleges older places that caught the
news
Harvard Yale Penn and I would number
Columbia very much
among them indeed Columbia probably took
more of the juice than any of the other
universities for a while it was quite
capable of forgetting that it had an
undergraduate program or an
undergraduate legacy but all of them
became full-fledged universities in the
sense that we know it today and in those
universities there was a first
generation of American academics with
scholarly interests in the distant parts
of the world again the term one uses I
always liked Archibald Cary Coolidge's
reference to those parts of the un--
hunt the unhealthy countries he called
them so ya sense what what a Bostonian
would think of the rest of the world but
Coolidge and others saw themselves less
as academic Empire abilities of although
I concede him acknowledged the point of
building up a library connection
collection being very much part of what
his overall plan was but less Empire
villages in one sense than go-betweens
and couriers than ambassadors Kenneth
Scott LaTourette at Yale serves that
function brings China back to New Haven
Herbert Eugene Bolton does Latin America
brings it to Berkeley California Oh he'd
be another example of a librarian
centered person James Henry breasted
brings the Middle East to the universe
issue cargo most relevant here is
Coolidge and it was the Slavic world
that he brought to Harvard after trying
and then deciding that diplomacy was not
something that he was he was cut out for
took a PhD not on in Russian studies or
anything like it at Freiburg
but then came to the Harvard history
department why president only it's a
friend of the family that's how it was
done this was not a this is not a
national search done with full
transparency Sunday dinner probably
settled it and Coolidge takes up it also
made it easy
I wasn't going to exact a salary and so
again if academic circumstances do get
desperate you can try that that gambit
if you wish you if you come for free
they might do you something Lionel
trilling here in the 1930s struggling to
make is luring on an instructorship with
his wife who was then ill and unemployed
and a father and mother who were living
way over their means over in Brooklyn so
he was the sole sole financial source of
support for them went to his department
chairman and asked what does one do in
this case and the Chairman said you have
to start eating into your capital Oh No
not having any you're in trouble so it's
cool it's you who really gets Larvik
studies going of course on the Balkans
contemporary Balkans and the Near East
in 1897
a year-long course on Russian history
the following year made librarian have
heard in 1910 again why no longer
Elliott his family friend but Eric
Lawrence Lowell his cousin who's
president turns to him probably another
Sunday lunch and said how would you like
to become a librarian Coolidge can
report a year after taking on that job
for the Far East we have perhaps the
best working library out of Washington
for Russia and the other Slav countries
the best not in Slavic languages in the
United States for the Ottoman Empire and
the Near East in question perhaps the
best in the world and then he went on to
train those people who has as it was
pointed out all properly this morning
set up Slavic Studies at Stanford at
Berkeley added other institutions and
then made sure at Harvard that they were
well supplied with people who could
carry the process on wiener right after
him Samuel Isaac cross and then William
Langer taking it down into the 1950s but
even with those interest Coolidge was at
least as interested
making contact with non-academic
communities of influence some of his
proudest graduates were those who went
on to diplomacy Joseph C Group who
became perhaps the most distinguished of
the professional Foreign Service
operatives in the United States ending
up as ambassador to Japan in the night
late 1930s was just one example it was
important to Coolidge and important to
Coolidge his students that when Coolidge
went to the State Department
the doorman recognized that he had a
place in this book and he helped found
not the Slavic review or even help find
found the American Islamic Association
but he helped found Foreign Affairs in
1919 which was a magazine addressed to
the international minded American
audience again not an academic when he
died Coolidge in 1928 Charles Homer
Haskins amid evilest said he snapped a
link between us he meant most narrowly
the Harvard History Department somewhat
more broadly Harvard but I think in
other words the whole university
community he snapped a link between us
in the world of big affairs and I think
that's right
into war academisation which is the
process that I've been talking what got
underway in in that period but slowly
the PhD had become a certificate of
expertise
there were promotional committees the
Committee on the promotion of Chinese
studies in the 1920s is one of the early
examples foundations had started to give
some money Carnegie and Rockefeller Ward
is still into selling cars at that point
not providing our funding but something
on the order of 30 or 40 PhDs were
generated in the 1930s in areas that I
can retrospectively describe as
international studies 2/3 of them in the
social sciences 1/3 and language and
literature nearly all of them were
awarded by five institutions Harvard
Columbia Chicago
you for all of them I think they
considered an affordable extravagance a
little bit like back in the 1890s there
was a rush for every University that was
going to be able to claim itself to be a
real University had to have a Sanskrit
is you didn't have to have to be crazy
to have to but you needed one oh and the
person would be paraded around at the
appropriate time rather like Nobel Prize
winners at some stage of the game
outside those half-dozen universities it
was an unaffordable expense and if you
were interested in in those fields and
taught outside that world are you either
get to get yourself into that world or
come up with something else
to earn your living then the war came
and everything changed this is the
Second World War and what we have is the
ascendance of the American academic
estate in general but in International
Studies in particular as well the
biggest beneficiaries of the Second
World War
institutional beneficiaries with the
American research universities and
within those universities physicists
I'll concede probably came in number one
they lived off their situation until the
biologists have permanently put them
aside but second to them were the people
in International Studies they found
themselves in demand which is itself
kind of you know levitating our
experience after having small classes
and being sort of on the margin where
the department is run by someone doing
English history or American history
William Lane William Langer in 1940
asked by his 25th anniversary class to
comment on his what what he's been doing
since he graduated my career has been
the rather unruffled one of university
teacher proverbially ensconced behind
the ivory tower that had been a
situation up to 1940 12 months later
he's at the recruiting officer for the
OSS and bringing into all sorts of
exciting nefarious activities during the
Second World War it was his rolodex in
effect that put the OSS together look to
Colombia and you take Gerald Robinson
and Phillip Mosley look to Penn and you
take the Sanskrit Asst W Norman Brown
you look to Chicago and you take the
archaeologist John a Wilson and you put
them all in trench coats and you send
them off you're not all parachuted into
France but they have exciting careers
and they are a very different crowd when
they come back from the war and in turn
how they pick off some of their bright
graduated students and recruit them as
well some of those did fly in to North
Africa and other places so that there's
a generation that gets equipped in a
particular way this is how Moseley
described it he a prominent figure here
in pressing when when Columbia sent
Moseley downtown to the Ford Foundation
to to rattle their cage they had to be
ready for him this was a tough guy
coming down and you just hope you didn't
give it all away
Harvard was coming the next day in
Chicago but if Columbia got there first
and they incent Mosley it was serious
business and you checked your pockets
afterward to see whether you had
anything left Mosely describing himself
obviously people with experience in
public service or in the social sciences
or both who were able to feel their way
and identify the needs and point them
out that's what they were that's it's
not that high grade exams very
effectively or a wonderful mentor to PhD
students but I can move and shake the
world and that's what I'm going to do
well they began pointing out these
situations not to the federal government
because we're still 20 years away from
overcoming the southern resistance to
federal aid education not to Washington
federal ages two decades off but to the
foundations to Carnegie and Rockefeller
they brought to them a potent argument
our ignorance got us into trouble read
second world war
knowledge will keep us secure knowledge
will let us win not I want to be secure
because months after the end of the
Second World War we're into the Cold War
so in 1945 is indicated early the
Russian Institute comes into being here
at Columbia with money from Rockefeller
in 1947 the Russian research center
comes into being in Cambridge or with
money from Carnegie Carnegie also that
year set up the Center for Japanese
studies at the University of Michigan
and it probably means from that date on
Michigan was first among equals at least
in stories and then the money just kept
coming columbia received 21 million
dollars from the Ford Foundation to set
up all sorts of activities there was not
an area studies program that existed
anyplace else that Columbia wasn't ready
to replicate thank the Ford Foundation
bikini news say couldn't you centralized
focus on something no we want to do it
all and down they would come and back
they would come with the money
these were the years that were fat in
1967 there were probably 600 PhDs
awarded in what I would call
international studies 22% of them came
from the top half dozen universities so
there's still concentration but that
second tier though but I was sent to
check out we're beginning to provide a
very significant portion of what was
going on so it was no longer quite so
top-heavy still talking about research
universities we're still talking about
more privates than public's but this
some sort of spread going on little was
made of that I think it's significant
because what that spread suggests a
certain kind of strength that couldn't
be there if you just depended on Harvard
and Columbia and Yale to do the heavy
lifting in those days 1960s Russian and
Slavic studies were one of the two most
favored of foreign area programs along
with East Asia although even East Asia
had its problems on that question who
lost China and some academics had to
keep their heads down
for a decade until McCarthy and company
passed before they could make themselves
sue welcome again at least in Washington
the middle east relatively poor and
under tended cousin but only relatively
poor lot in America depending on what
Fidel was doing if the Cuban situation
could heat up in Latin American Studies
good money
we went quiet than land study got off to
the side the pattern here at Columbia is
very much that East Asian Sarek Studies
part of the core of the University Latin
America no African in the same situation
now but meanwhile more and more people
are coming then this federal funding
precipitated by one view by the Russian
launching at Sputnik in the fall of 1957
within months the National Defense
Education Act is passed and it includes
the title six provisions that still
represent a significant portion of the
support that international studies get
ok my last data point this neh Summer
Institute the funder National Endowment
for Humanities I didn't pay a cent and
I'm getting my lunch paid for it alright
the host Columbia University still in
the business actually getting better at
it
one might say the directors with real
experience in mounting these summer
Institute's so this kind of
infrastructure if you will
accommodating and supportive employers
some of the people who employ you we
haven't all gone to a 12-month schedule
or some of us do get some time to be
doing some things during the academic
year other than our meeting or teaching
responsibilities and someone's got to
pay for that eurasia again for an
American is a fairly distant part of the
world I mean I have a secondary interest
besides universities it's more
time history you ain't got no oceans
mostly you know it's a dry part of it
too so it doesn't strike me that this
would necessarily be representative of
the center of International Studies but
there were 60 applicants for this
program drawn from all over the country
again the difference is I'm pointing to
are ones that speak to the embeddedness
of International Studies in the larger
academic enterprise with changes let me
give you three or four be lucky four or
five changes that are represented by
what I can see here many more women than
twenty-five years ago more than half the
Institute fellows are women more
scholars from the regions they are
studying well that is to say native
speakers or people who were born in
regions that fall into the Eurasian
group that was predicted if all went
well and so far as it has is it in the
process of occurring I think it's a sign
of Health International Studies for me
because I think if it were if it were
dying on the vine there would be fewer
and fewer of you in total but I think
the demographics would be different well
more of you have credentials for more
institutions than would have been the
case in the 1940s or in the in the 1960s
there are more disciplines in scholarly
fields included when you did Slavic
Studies at one point you had someone
doing literature you had somebody doing
political science history but art
history not early on I don't think
sociology maybe but that's that's no
longer the case these are these are not
areas that we're only anthropologists go
or only economists are interested these
areas were Americans
our studying and bringing the
disciplinary interest with them how 16
different US universities are
represented here and no single
university more than a couple of people
Rutgers USC Columbia by my count more
disciplines in scholarly fields to be
sure old standbys history language and
lit I still here economics in political
science but art history anthropology
information sciences architecture or
library science a dispersion and I think
a healthy one then I would also say that
your teaching at more kinds of
institutions so the point I was making
earlier about the penetration of liberal
arts colleges is even I think can be
made more as a result of what I can see
here today we're penetrating deeper when
I thought of liberal arts colleges I was
thinking of the sort of traditional
aside from Grinnell and Pomona New
England middle of West liberal arts
colleges and they barn it being one of
them but we represent eight or nine
percent of the academic world and it's a
declining proportion all living or
foreign endowments and the promise that
we can get you into business school
easier than someplace else can get you
in to business school but there is a an
institutional mix out there that is
represented here Hawaii Pacific College
of Staten Island Georgia College the
University of South Florida are on the
University of South Carolina Deacon
board University of wisconsin-green Bay
our barb Jones University drew okay
finally that you find yourself doing
work in a region of the world and it's
many languages the 20 years ago was as
much at such removed from American
concerns as to not even rate being
considered by neglected that is the term
was not really applied I went back and
looked and I did find one at the time in
my book a reference to your part of the
world if you will so there's a certain
embarrassment here
because I use the reference to show how
reductive an argument could be made to
the point of absurdity that if you were
arguing that we're neglecting it you
could push that as an infinite
regression there and here as you'll find
out who was at the end of that
regression this was I had to say and it
was with reference to an article by
Dennis in awe at the at Indiana
University wrote in 1964 and he titled
it the neglected area in American
International Studies in my response to
it wiseass as ever the specter of
sufficiency could be indefinitely put
off by subdividing world areas to
suggest for example the D station
studies was taken care of and to point
to work being done in China as evidence
was to strengthen the case for
additional support for Japanese studies
to support proposals for additional
study of Japan was to invite proposals
for those prepared to study Korea and
Mongolia likewise to approximate
comprehensive disciplinary courage in
one world area was to point out the spot
enos of such coverage elsewhere to
provide a South Asian program with
language instruction in Hindi Bengali a
nerd who only revealed the neglect of
Tamils
Marathi and Punjabi then my final try
had reductio had CERN which I meant to
be definitive here in 1964 uronic and
I'll take were described by an Indiana
University professor as quote the
neglected area in his view of American
University courage of the non-western
world not because they were not several
universities teaching neurotic and
Altaic but because that only one his
Indiana University was there a
free-standing ironic Altaic department I
went to google and looked up Indiana
you'll be pleased to know insured
fortified perhaps Indiana University's
Department is still there it's changed
its title slightly but that it goes with
the territory as to the department of
central Eurasian Studies and while I was
at this research site nice to say Google
I made a quick search
that yielded 15 other universities with
language and culture programs with
Eurasia in its title to be sure at
Indiana it has an interracial you're all
ik National Resource Center and in that
sense probably has been able to maintain
its preeminence or in that field but all
of this is yes to me that when times do
look tough and again we spend a lot of
time lunch dealing with the California
education system and I think that does
qualify us
times are tough I think the long term
view of International Studies provides
yet another testament to the
survivability in a the staying power of
American academic enterprise so I wish
you good luck and thanks for having me
you